This is just like the other ones,
but I didn't send it to you.
How many of these boxes did you create?
Five. One for each of my friends.
No test boxes, no prototypes?
My puzzle guy barely
got the five done in time,
and he apprenticed with Ricky Jay.
And once the boxes are open
and the puzzles completed,
is there any way to close them again?
To reset them?
Hang on. Hang on.
Someone reset the box.
They sent it to you as a gag.
“Miles is doing a murder mystery.
Let's invite Benoit freaking Blanc.”
Oh, it's so good.
I am mortified. I don't--
Why?
I've got the predefinite detective
in the world at my murder mystery party.
That is so legit.
Mr. Bron, I've learned through
bitter experience
that an anonymous invitation
is not to be trifled with.
Okay, look, come on. I'd love to
have you visit me in my home.
There, you've been invited.
You're an official guest now.
Thrilled to have you.
I mean, relax. Enjoy yourself.
Hey, try to solve
the murder mystery if you can.
I don't want to toot my own horn,
but it's pretty next level.
I'm going to foil.
I'll see you at the pool.